uh  i mean he plays very much under control  i believe  sure but he was white yesterday  against rajabov with black i don't see  it happening but i could be wrong he  plays one e for rajabov  it's already a sign  that franchise does not want to play it  super solid in subquery situ names  though  what so we have we have the petrov on  the board  in karana nepameshi  both guys had this as their main weapon  in their respective world championship  matches  so it's two giant specialists here  very curious where karana goes knight f3  knight takes e4  will he play knight c3 will he play d4  well i it just came occurred to me that  if let's say magnus really going to  not only say but it will be an action  that he's not going to be defending his  title and these two players will be  playing them the world championship  match it's picture of every game